Jamal sweet dreams Hill is one of the
better athletes in the slight
heavyweight Division I think he probably
has the best natural power of any light
heavyweight right now he's a willing
Grappler he's an underappreciated
Grappler but that's Clover to shara's
world man so I do think Jamal Hill has
got to be very mindful of that as
confident as he is in his grappling in
his transitions in his submission
defense I just don't think you want to
floor fight with the Ageless Clover to
share you always got to root for for uh
to share journeyman in the sport made
some big things happen later on his
career ages he's awesome every time you
see him at any fights he's just one of
the nicest guys as well too so that's
what I'm moving for I want him all the
win I understand that if it goes on the
ground he probably won't win so Jamal
has a better striking better footwork I
understand this one's going to be 50 50
so I don't have a prediction but I hope
Jamal wins
[Music]